it will haunt you every night whatever
it is no one should have to encounter
that kind of evil except you girls I
think you can handle it oh oh good
thanks
we have a gift we see what no one else
is willing to see we do things others
can't do those buses if there's a
paranormal problem we are the ones to
answer the call hello the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen what do we think of
these ghostbusters are they to be taken
seriously I'll take the far one okay you
sweaty freak
how about to save you from that okay so
I don't know if it was a race thing or a
lady thing but I'm mad as hell there's a
bigger picture at hand here someone is
creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity we're gonna need a
bigger boat
hey guys check it out Kevin come inside
I was born to be a Ghostbuster right oh
man that's so not good
something big is going to happen the
work we're looking for is apocalypse
yeah the government's trying to claim
the event isn't supernatural we don't
want a panic
you don't want mass hysteria and you
especially you don't know you got a
young no I'm tired
no no just don't go ahead and take off
how about that I don't really think
that's a good I don't going to take off
don't piss off the ghost really someone
is creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity and they might be
the only ones who can stop it
Holtzman come on